- You kind of really
have blinders on
and don't let yourself become comfortable
and play it safe.
You can't take on a job because
oh, well, what am I,
well, this has got to be a good one.
You have to just always go by your gut.
- She an American actress,
producer, and businesswoman.
She gained worldwide fame
for playing Rachel Green
on the TV sitcom Friends.
She's one of the highest paid actresses
in Hollywood.
She's Jennifer Aniston
and here's my take on her
top ten rules for success.
Rule number two is my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick around
all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
Also, as Jennifer is talking,
if she says something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it
so that other people can be inspired.
And also, when you write it down,
it's much more likely to stick
in your head, too.
Enjoy.
(electronic whooshing)
(dramatic music)
I think I was getting stuck myself,
feeling nervous to take a chance and
forgetting the fact that I'm an actor
and I can play different parts
and I've been on,
I used to do character shows
or sketch comedy shows
where I would do hundreds of characters.
And all of sudden you get very safe
and very, you can feel stuck.
And not only do you feel stuck,
but the world
sort of sticks you somewhere.
They put you in a little box
and in a category.
And so,
what I learned from it was don't listen.
You got to really have blinders on,
and don't let yourself become
comfortable and play it safe
'cause you'll burn out.
And I want to do this for a while.
I want to be around for
a little while longer.
- [Interviewer] When
a script comes to you,
when somebody's sending you a script,
what, are you looking character first?
Are you looking story first?
Are you looking for the
whole project and how?
- The whole kit and caboodle.
I'd say the character, the story,
and am I going to have a really good time?
Am I going to connect to it?
Doesn't have to be real serious or this.
Could be a big blockbuster hit comedy
and I just want it to be really fun
and enjoyable.
The outcome's always going to be,
you never know what the
outcomes going to be.
And you can't do it for...
You can't take on a job because,
oh, well what am I,
well, this has got to be a good one.
You have to just always go by your gut
and if you're going to enjoy yourself
and have good time creatively.
And work with people.
Time saver: don't work with angry people.
Don't work with pain in the ass actors.
Don't work with, you know,
get all your information and say,
yeah, life's too short rule.
That falls under that.
I will move on.
- You and I both believe
that you call things into your life.
- Yes.
- And that things happen as they should
when you're ready for it to happen.
- That's right.
The other day,
I was doing yoga with my girlfriend.
And we finished, and we
were sort of sitting there
just sort of stretching.
And I looked over at her and I said,
you know what, I have to say
I'm feeling a feeling I have,
I don't know if I've actually felt before.
And that is
that I don't want to by anywhere other
than where I am right now.
Sitting across from you.
(audience applauds)
And that means
I'm not sitting somewhere
dwelling on the past
or I'm not fretting or obsessing
about something in the future
or something that was...
You know, it was just a
feeling of total peace.
And I love that.
- Well how did you get there?
'Cause you had to shed some tears.
You had to have some moments.
- Well, sure.
- [Oprah] Where you
thought, like, oh my god.
- Me not shed a tear?
Come on.
- [Oprah] Yeah, please, yeah.
- So you know, although I did not
burst into tears at the
opening of that article
by the way, I'll just say that.
But anyway.
- [Oprah] So you shed some tears?
- So I shed some tears,
but meaning, you know,
it's sort of that living in the moment.
In the now as they say.
And all the self-help books,
'cause if I had a dollar for every book
that was sent my way.
(audience laughs)
I could have probably
paid for this studio.
(audience laughs)
You know.
- You would have needed
two dollars for that.
- [Jennifer] Two dollars for every book?
(audience applauds)
- [Oprah] Two dollars for every book.
But yeah, you can read the books.
- You can read them and you can sort of
intellectualize it, but the truth is,
and you sit there going,
well how do I do that.
And you're frustrated
and then you get down
on yourself because you're not there yet.
And then you just realized one day
it's just happened.
It's collected in your, you know,
your cellular memory.
And then one day you're sitting there
with your friend doing yoga and you go,
oh, I get it.
- [Oprah] I'm okay.
- I get it.
You know, we all have
varying degrees of loss
and sadness and pain in our lives,
and it's a necessity honestly
'cause then how would we appreciate
the good times and the hopeful times
and all of the abundance that life has
if you go and grab it.
But it's a personal choice
to get up and move on
and be better.
I was saying the other day to somebody,
I think all actors
who are maybe
gratefully, successful
sometimes, if you are identified
with something like Friends,
you almost feel like you're an actor
in a closet always trying like...
I want to do more, you know what I mean?
And it's always,
there's always a little bit
of a struggle and a challenge.
But I find that exciting,
you know what I mean?
To keep pushing myself
and to keep challenging myself
and taking risks.
I think it's important not to get lazy
and stay safe.
You have to understand,
when you have nothing to compare it to,
and you just get to go to work
and you see so many of your friends
who are not working,
I'm just grateful to be working
and doing movies
that I found fun and entertaining.
And some were beloved and some were not.
You know, and then it
wasn't until I got really,
starting getting older where I realized
I think having done The Good Girl,
it made me really sort of
realize, oh, I have a
choice of what I can do.
I really can explore other things
and not just sit back and just wait
for what's handed to you.
So I think I started back then making
being more conscious and vocal
with my managers and agents about stuff.
Areas that I wanted to explore.
- You know, you've been
into yoga for years
and you also meditate.
- [Jennifer] Yes.
- So what are some of the biggest changes
that that has brought to your life?
- You know,
it's kind of not one thing
you can point at or put a finger on.
It's just...
I can tell you that I feel...
It's like a kick start for your day.
It just centers you.
And things,
your stress levels are just down.
And you find yourself
interacting in the world
much easier and better,
and in a calmer way.
And there's just a peaceful joy
that sort of comes over.
And you can't,
I don't know how or why,
it's no rhyme or reason.
And I just know that if I,
if I go through a phase where I slip off
and I'm not as religious with it,
I feel the difference.
I just feel it.
- Yeah, and for people
that are maybe a little bit intimidated
about taking up meditation,
what can you tell them?
- Just, there's nothing to do wrong.
You can't do it wrong.
You could go take a class if you want.
You can have someone come
to give you training in it.
Or you can just find something
that works for you.
You can just listen to beautiful music
and just find gratitude
in whatever is here
or in what you have.
All I can say is you can't mess it up.
- Have you ever again, no names.
- No names.
- But have you ever accepted a project
and then been into it a couple of weeks,
and said, not to the world and not to me,
but to your best friend,
oh, I don't think this is
what I expected it to be.
- Yes I have.
(audience laughs)
- [Interviewer] All right, so now,
no names was our deal, but...
- Like I'm going to actually name a name.
(audience laughs)
That would just not happen.
- [Interviewer] But how do you
get through that then?
- How do you get through it?
You have to do...
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
'cause you're three weeks
into it and then you've got another
three or four or six weeks of shooting.
- You make the best of it.
You just take care of your job.
You know, and you talk
and you have as much of a dialogue
with them as you possibly can.
And, you know, just get in there.
Get very involved.
Sometimes you can just sit back
and you can just do your job.
And sometimes it's
important that you kind of
be a bit more collaborative, you know.
I was always a yo yo dieter.
I was a chubbier kid.
- But did you do drastic things to diet?
- No.
Was I just bulimic or anorexic?
No, but I was a diet-aholic.
Definitely.
Grapefruit diet I remember.
There was the watermelon diet.
There was the white grain of rice diet.
- [Press] Jennifer.
- [Interviewer] But these days
she says it's different.
She works out three to four days a week
and has learned to make eating
about life now,
not a reaction to the past.
A father who broke up the family
and a volatile mother.
- I want to say to all these young girls
there are so many struggles
that everybody has,
especially when it's like
you don't know what you're filling up.
Are you filling up a void?
Is it your father leaving?
Is it,
is it your fear of failure?
Is it that I will never be that thin?
I will never be as beautiful as you,
whoever you are.
And then I think once you become,
once you figure out your,
you know, who you are
and what you love about yourself
I think it all kind of
falls into place eventually.
- All right, so here's how we play.
We're going to take turns acting out
clues to the other person
and they have to guess
the word in the monitor.
So there's going to be a word behind me.
I can't see it.
We each have one minute
to get the other person
to guess as many as we can.
And you're the guest.
I'm going to let you go first.
- Okay.
- And so it's here, and I'll have to guess
as many in one minute as I can.
- Okay.
(xylophone chimes)
- Game is cuing up.
Get ready.
- Oh it's like, okay.
- Jump rope.
(bell dings)
Hula hoop, hula.
- Oh, oh.
- Oh.
(audience laughs)
- Snow angel, snow angels.
(bell dings)
- Oh my god, oh god.
- Twerking.
(bell dings)
- Oo, oo, oo, oo.
- You're a monkey or you're a gorilla.
(bell dings)
- You're running man, running.
- Cheering, cheerleader.
(bell dings)
- Oh, oh god.
(buzzer buzzes)
(audience applauds)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video
because Orsolia asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
what did Jennifer say
that had the biggest impact on you?
What lesson are you
going to take from this
and immediately apply it to your life
or your business?
Leave it down in the comments.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to M.D. McGill.
Thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book, You're One Word,
and taking that awesome picture
on what looks like an amazing,
sunny, beautiful day.
I hope you enjoy the read.
And thank you for sharing.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(electronic whooshing)
- What would you say
to your 20 year old self, though?
- Oh, my 20 year old self
- [Adam] Who was cute, by the way.
- I would say enjoy it.
- [Adam] Oh yeah, that's good.
- That's, I really...
- That's true.
- [Jennifer] But it's true, it's...
- Enjoy it.
- [Jennifer] Enjoy it.
- yeah.
- This is really...
- Don't fret so much.
- No fretting.
This is a really wonderful thing
that we get to do to make people laugh
and to entertain people.
- [Adam] Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And it's, we're lucky.
So enjoy that.
And listen to people when they tell you
how much joy you bring
to their living rooms
or their movie.
- [Oprah] Pay attention.
- Pay attention.